what is our motivation for the way we
spend our money are we trying to impress
others are we trying to impress
ourselves are we trying to live up to
some big you know dream or what other
people think that we should have but
what about starting to look and see what
do you really want to do - Derick ham
this is my wife Latrice and we're
currently in Tampa Florida so when we
started this journey we had 126 thousand
dollars in debt but it took us around 26
months to pay it off and it was it was
hard sometimes we had to make a lot of
sacrifices we had to get very
resourceful we had to do a lot of
self-reflection we had to learn how to
say no this really helped us to grow
into into what our family should be I am
what we're both engineers for the
government I work in RF engineering and
she works more networking for me growing
up I was good with saving money but I
was also good with spending all the
money I'm saying
it was definitely not a good way to live
and good way to plan for the future but
it was a finite consciousness I always
worked hard and tried to save money but
unfortunately my parents didn't really
know how to manage their own money so I
kinda had to learn on my own sometimes
we got married we bought two cars at the
same time so we have credit card bills
we had a car two Cardinals and we had
student loans that was the majority of
what we had to pay off
how old was our marriage I can't
remember year two into the mare
truly realize we weren't doing it right
once I started actually seeing the
numbers that's when I was like all we
got to do better our turning point was
when we got home from a Christmas
vacation there it needs new tires on his
truck why are we stressing out about
getting new tires this makes no sense
and so that's what I knew like the buck
stops here we have got to get our
finances in order we have got to face
the music she comes around wanting to do
date the the course the class that was
offered at our church
I gotta fail I was probably the best
thing that was the best thing that ever
happened to it yeah he did not want to
go he was Kim's like well you could just
take notes for me I grew up in a
household where they operated separately
it was the his and hers and I said no
we're not going to do that there'll be
our money we started putting putting the
budget together and actually seeing what
we had coming in and what was going out
it really started expanding the way we
thought as far as you know what was
really important and what we needed to
do versus what we what we wanted to do
now we actually had to put what we've
been preaching the practice and we were
making so many extra payment the
interest wasn't racking up and so we
were actually paying a lot quicker than
we thought we would have it done which
actually pushed our date from like I
think June or May June to like February
because because we make it so we was so
aggressive on it this class taught us
that really you can live in this world
without owing any man any debt it gave
us the the opportunity to dream again
this was huge and so for us to fight
through this it just makes us feel like
hey we could do anything we could do
anything a lot of people go on diets or
try to do quick fixes with with their
finances but then they're back into you
know using credit cards in fact in the
and this this kind of taught part of how
to have a life change that that has
really freed us as far as what we want
to do for our family
[Music]
also since we've been debt-free we were
we've been able to be foster parents we
were able to actually foster a young kid
and and pour into his life and we were
also able to we were trying to have
another baby in order to have another
baby we had to do IVF and and since
since then we were able to do it and not
go into debt doing it and and we were
blessed to have another child now we can
actually create a legacy for our
children whereas before we didn't think
in those kind of terms when you think
about freedom right we thought we were
free right we really did but getting out
of that this whole journey of becoming
debt-free has taught us what true
financial freedom feels like I don't
want I don't want to have to owe anybody
money I want to make my own decisions I
don't want to have to you know say I got
to pay this bill I got to do this you
know I owe this you just started getting
a little upset that you that you owe
money I believe what the Bible says I
believe that you know we are the head
and not the tail we are above and not
beneath we are lender not a borrower
right so we pay these things we pray
these things all the time what was
missing was us actually doing the work
whether I have $50,000 if I have a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars it is
all in how you manage it because I
believe what God said and his word was
true and so I was going from stick to it
my part and I saw that he did show up
and bless us tremendously on one change
- see you shocking this that I'm the
eldest
[Music]
three what in a God be the glory
what happened
[Music]